how's the big Hot Cheetos them starburst
star that starburst I'll start oh my god
starboard starboard oh my goodness
today we're swapping American and German
snacks the TV and snacks with my best
friends I was pretty much the kid that
never uses lunch money at school right
and then just ran to the gas station
bought up everything then the logic oh
yeah so what American snack to be tried
I haven't had an Oreo before I came to
the States so I know I know but you had
I had yes I'm the big chips fan I like
chips sometime we basically had to the
World Championship in Germany in 2006
and we ate a lot of these chips that we
call the chips fresh so what are you
guys eating when you watch American
football uh laze ruffles and like bean
dip to ready to try American snacks
absolutely yes pie let's do this so
these are ruffles it's a staple in any
party or the Super Bowl this is
mozzarella and marinara flavor any type
of food that we have in America we turn
it into a chip there we go people by the
interesting thing about it is it's
called ships fridge right which is chips
and you know and then fish is fresh and
this is very interesting too because I
mean garnished I know what it actually
means
Hungarian any Hungarian that I decide to
lick no if you have a party you would
usually bring this or have it they're
just just as ruffles so this is pretty
Super Bowl that's where the absolutely
open that file on please good good it's
like a potato dressing up as another
fruit like the paprika
that'll prop Rica tasty yeah they kind
of taste like barbecue Lay's I don't
know that oh it actually tastes like
what it says on the bag so you don't
even have to eat much I like those but
I'm not sure if I would buy them I would
still go with those because it just
brings back so many memories
okay like this more then than that these
are good again but if I'm gonna be doing
snacking for a while you have German
yeah I mean he's half German I made him
half German right now those are called
hanuta it's like a hazelnut cream
between two wafers yes positiveness NATO
has the new Schmidt Schmidt s'en I mean
honestly guys huh new ties I think one
of the most popular snacks that we have
in Germany I had those as a kid many
many times Nutter butters peanut buttery
flavor real bold it's peanut butter in
the shape of a peanut Oh
boom there you go smell is very strong
it's okay yeah it's a mini sandwich yeah
so you don't have to spread the Nutella
it's not too big you know it's not
really like you see it's like that the
it's not like to do crackers are
basically almost like bigger than that
and the actual cream the peanut butter
is still somewhat savory like not not a
sweet but the the cookie makes it super
sweet it's very interesting but I love
it I'll run with this yeah yeah I'm just
geremy snacks are just going it tonight
and I keep very partial to Nutella so
but I think it would pick this oh yeah I
think I would go with this because this
is more exciting this is new when
interesting and weird and just I can't
explain why I love it but I do bodybow
cool that flusher
it tastes like coca-cola in the shape of
a cola yes it's a very German
traditional companies like from a guy
out of bond which is a German town his
name is I think it was hunted he shuts
from bonds for Hans H a RI for Richard B
Obon Haribo and I love by the way this
has sheer size and it's it's a fairly
whole bag
we got the trolley sour bright
are you a fan of yeah this is obviously
not share sighs yeah you expect but it's
the same it does taste like hope since
there's no life busyness is just like
flat code it was actually not sour at
all this is not taste like coal well I
would never buy him but I would eat him
if somebody offered me some I mean you
know I feel duped das is nicht okay I
like him
they actually not too sour actually
these are right in the middle I like it
you know it's not tooth no it's too
crazy so it's very sweet and it tastes
very artificial I don't know what
flavour they're going for power time we
just have to go with the trolleys just
because they're sour man I go with into
there we go I do
sorry if Germany I mean I love you you
know what right but I would do this no
question I would choose Oh interesting
my favorite thing was Anita Anita
oh it's honey yeah I knew that so I
would say my favorite today was the the
Nutter Butter I just like the weirdness
of it for me I'm the opposite I love
chocolate so my favorite is the hunt I'm
definitely did trolley sour gummy bears
or like octopus that's definitely also
one of my favorites no I think in the
future if I'm just somewhere at a party
or whatever and they have stuff like
that that's the first I'm gonna look for
a lot of weird combinations and very
intense flavors but overall very
interesting I mean I like the German
stop obviously you know so I can't
really say anything bad us about the
American stuff it's just different
right and I really feel it just depends
how you got raised and where you're
coming from
I'm more into the American like candies
but it seems like crackers and potato
chips
I like picture of innovations
[Music]